good morning heck it's tuesday i missed
you so much that i green screened myself
into your background
just kidding
i don't like when you do the thing where
you put your chair up slightly higher
than mine so you appear taller
lower lower
there we go hello welcome to question
tuesday
what is your favorite tick tock sound
you can really die
wow you can't really dance sarah told me
actually she had a dream last night that
you and i were trying to make a tick
tock to the
wow you can really dance while they were
like trying to like get us to leave to
like go do family stuff
what is your favorite essay in the
anthropocene reviewed book the first one
that got me that made me cry was the
the was it is it the first one in the
book the liverpool one yeah
you'll never walk alone man it must be
so like
enjoyable to uncover that like there is
a depth there
oh yeah that even the people who really
enjoy it don't know about it the thing
about non-fiction that i prefer
to fiction is that in fiction the things
that happen have to make sense
and in non-fiction that's like fit the
theme yeah yeah
the non-fiction the things can just be
true and in the case if you'll never
walk alone the true story
of the song is so phenomenally good what
would hank and john from 10 years ago
say if you could time travel
and tell them everything i think myself
from 10 years ago would be like oh that
sounds cool
that's awesome that's that sounds that's
a little scary
yeah and then too many slices
too many that's like two slices i don't
need another slice
that's that's what they would say yeah
how about you i think i'd say
what is doge and why do you want me to
buy it
and then sell it and then buy it again
and then sell it again at a very
specific schedule how do peppers work
which kind it i think i don't ask the
questions here
oh is the less ripe ones green and the
most ripe ones red
oh no no they're different varieties
these kinds of peppers
would you rather have mint flavored gum
or fruit flavored gum
mint yeah first off fruit flavored gum
does not taste like any fruit
it tastes like you described fruit to an
artificial intelligence that then ran
a thousand simulations of what fruit
might taste like and then was like
here's some fruit flavored gum hank
what's going on with the crash course
coins
so yesterday we just launched this new
project the crash course coins
uh yeah i have i have them here in my
hand cut to a close-up
cut to close-ups crash course reaches
like 70 million students
a year and we are looking to continue to
be able to do that there's a 100
one that will allow us to reach 2 000
learners and a 500
one that will allow us to reach 10 000
learners we're only making 500 of those
what kind of inconsequential brotherly
arguments do you get into
hank acted as if i stole money from
his trophies which he did he would he
would roll up the money into his
trophies and then i would steal it i
would definitely steal it and i bought
all kinds of things
you're saying you're saying that i acted
as if a thing that happened happened
yeah yeah but then you didn't
contextualize it properly i used most of
the money to buy baseball cards
which you sold without my permission
when we were in college
i believe i believe you i can't i and
like it does seem like a thing
where i would have convinced myself that
that's okay my baseball card collection
on ebay
it was i learned so much about business
and commerce
it was a very valuable lesson you used
those that i then paid
to found dftba.com right i'm sure i'm
sure if you hadn't sold my baseball card
yet on ebay you never would have known
how ecommerce works
did you get emotional when you saw each
other in person yes
during the pandemic i have like
struggled to feel emotion
when the thing is happening yeah and i
kind of went oh it's very overwhelming
feel it later
yeah thanks for coming to our video hank
i will continue to see you now
hey what are we going to do on friday
for your video i don't know john
i don't have any plans oh i guess i do
have a point
don't don't